Forty two years and counting
our classmate Senator Edward M. Kennedy
thank you very much, and George
George Abrams
I don't think we could have had a class of
nineteen fifty four if we didn't have George Abrams
I will tell you
he has been so devoted to this the class over
so many years and I think
those that have been closely associated
with it
the know it and he's been a dear and
valued friend
he's been such a dear and valued friend that he's
put me on the last, I'm the last speaker that
you have
and I'm the last speaker before happy hour
and I don't know what it was
put me on at five minutes to five here but in any
event
I thank you George I know I did something
to you back there in those times
years ago but
I have
he's been a dear and valued friend he
and Mada
have been such dear friends to me
and I thank him for all he has done
for when he came to the United States senate
was the chairman of our refugee committee that
did so
impressive work down there and has been
so devoted to
this great celebration, really a pleasure
to be with George
let me
say a
word about my colleagues
I've
added up and it's been a pleasure to have
served and continue to serve with
all of them. I did my math among us we've
clocked a total of a hundred and eight years
in the senate and house of representatives
and
Connecticut good neighbor Nancy Johnson is a republican
power in the house
these days, it's always a pleasure to be with
her
and Tony Beilenson and I were both elected
at the age of thirty
he was the pioneer of the environmental issues
on family planning
national
health service
his son
he is a leader on these that issues in a
the leading a great city, has been selected
as the outstanding public servant
so he's not only had a great career myself
but he's inspired another generation so
it's a pleasure to be with Tony.
David Boehm was a voice of reason on civil
rights but it wasn't easy
a pleasure to be with him.
But it is a special place to be
with the an old friend a very dear friend
and
but John Culver and I have been vast friends
for
of some fifty years he helped me get started
in the united states
senate
after that went back
to Iowa, elected the
to the congress of the united states then
to the united states the senate
and in many ways the most enjoyable
years I spent in congress were the sixteen
great years that we served together and I
wish he was still there.
John
as
George mentioned, wrote a brilliant book
on Henry Wallace
I thought it deserved a Pulitzer prize
it is just the a very very special historical
document that is a great addition and help
in understanding
an extraordinary period of time in American
history
John I
as you remember particularly with regard to
John
had been a good football friends on campus
and
we made a good team in the senate, John was
the fullback carrying the
ball grinding out the yardage on the field
later on the issues
shaking off republican tacklers
I was the left end
which everyone thought was where I learned my
political philosophy
so, but thank you John
it's good to be here with the class of fifty
four and an article
in yesterday's Boston globe mentioned that
a pretty good case could be made for the class
as the Harvard’s greatest class, sounds good
to me,
the globe
the globe article also referred to a
certain class poll that
asked extraordinary personal and interesting
questions about
the reading habits
and shall we say lifestyle
of the members of the class.
I was interested to know that we read an
average
of seventeen books a year
and that
four percent
of the class
has a more interesting personal life
than ever before
well done class! well done!
fifty years so much has
changed in government and politics but so much
as the stayed the same
especially the power of the nation's ideals
to attract talented men and women
to public life.
I find the senate is every bit as inspiring
to me today as it was
in nineteen sixty two
the key to enacting
progressive legislation is very simple
ninety percent of it is hard work
and the other fifty percent
is Irish luck
I learned early from my brothers and from
my grandfather, the Boston mayor,
that the best way to meet a challenge
is to see an opportunity
and the miracle in Philadelphia in seventeen
eighty seven
makes it possible to treat every challenge
that way
we may not always live up to those ideals
but it's endlessly gratifying that so
many in each new generation are so eager to
try
and it's also gratifying that Harvard and
the school of government named for my brother
and it's institute of politics
are at the heart but that effort
you learn very quickly that young men and
women
are ready to sign on
for community and public service
if only somebody asked them
Harvard asked
and the response has been truly extraordinary
I've been in the united states senate for
nearly forty two years that
is not quite the fifty-year milestone that
we celebrate today for the class
of fifty four but it’s a lot longer than I ever
would have contemplated
when I first entered public life
and during those forty two years I've served
under nine
presidents four democrats five republicans
one of those presidents, my brother Jack,
was also a Harvard man and
his administration was filled with Harvard
men
and women including my brother Bob as an attorney
general
and from where I sit those were extraordinary
days in our nation's history and I'm so proud
and honored
to have been a part of them.
Throughout its history
throughout its history the senate has and
by and large been
an extraordinary collegial place
and with fierce opponents debating an issue
on the senate floor and then working together
to pass the legislation the next day
even in the fiercely partisan time during
the Clinton administration you could still find
that
kind of
collegiality.
I remember
one time when I was going to offer the minimum
wage
legislation, increase in the minimum wage
it's a legislation that was sponsored by
Senator Murkowski that was going to
increase the national parks
in communities around the country
and I went up to our leaders and to
Daschle and
I said you know
Senator Murkowski said that if I didn't
offer the amendment on the increase in
the minimum wage
he would put
my
parks, new national park which was new Bedford
which is the home of the Melville in the
great whaling tradition deserve on its
merits to be included in it
but if I offered the minimum wage he would
not include it
I told them
I said I'm still going to offer the minimum
wage
so I offered it we were defeated
and they call the roll
and the bill
carried and  Senator Murkowski came up to
me and said
well Senator Kennedy don't feel too bad about
that
because I left yours
but left out one of Bob Dole's who's the majority
leader
so it really wasn't partisan
because I left out his and left out yours
so I said well that helps out a lot and I thank
you very much
so they finish with the a roll call and the
senate wound up and I was
cleaning up my desk and I saw
Bob dole sitting over there
and that I said to Bob dole I said
oh what a about
another parks bill, national parks bill
he said what have you got mind
I say yours and mine
he was the majority leader at that time
he said
will Daschle clear that?
absolutely.
because Daschle knew
that I could have gotten mine in
but as a matter of
principle that I hadn't offered that thing
he said
draft it up
it passed in the next fifteen minutes his bill
his park and mine
the most interesting
it went to the conference
and when it got to the conference
there were those
with all deference to
my colleague here, republicans
that said okay we'll take Dole's
but we won't take yours
and dole said no
we went in together and we're coming back together
now that was collegiality
even though we differed with Bob dole on ninety
percent
that would no more happen today
that kind of working together that kind of
understanding
that kind of
opportunity just doesn't exist.
it's become a cliché to suggest that collegiality
is gone
and partisanship rules the day
but I don't think that tells the entire story
there's still time, for it's possible to reach
across the aisle to accomplish something good
for the American people, I had great hopes
for the no child left behind legislation but
those opportunities are harder to find
in any election season.
there is also a more personal tone in disagreements
these days
Until a few years ago no Senator would ever
dream of going to the floor
to mention another Senator by name
without first notifying that Senator in advance
thus the notified senator had the opportunity
to sit on the floor
the hear the other Senator take him to task
and usually in the quite
polite terms, the gentleman from Massachusetts,
and the like
without question the tone of the speeches
was much milder
when you had to look the opposing Senator
in the eye.
I recall that just a few years ago a republican
Senator went to the floor to challenge and
contradict
one of Senator Bob Byrd’s statements
and he mentioned
Senator Byrd by name without first notifying
and as the informal historian and keeper of
the senate tradition
Bob Byrd was livid at the breach of senate
procedure
he ran to the floor to excoriate the offending
Senator
for failing to notify in advance and by the end
of the episode the republican Senator was
publicly apologizing to Senator Byrd
and the substantive issue of disagreement
faded in the background
well the issue a protocol breached took
the center stage
unfortunately for the senate however
that sense of protocol is today honored more
often in the breach
perhaps not as it relates to Senator Byrd
but certainly as it relates to the ninety
nine
other members of the senate
this aggressive and personal partisanship
was not as evident
even ten years ago.
for example when Mitt Romney challenged me in
nineteen ninety four he asked Orrin Hatch
certainly a fierce republican partisan, to come
to Massachusetts to campaign for him
but Orrin was on the ranking member of the health
committee and I was the chairman and Orrin
refused to come in to Massachusetts
to campaign against me
collegiality particularly on our committee
trumped partisanship
contrast that with what we see today
in just this last month the senate majority
leader Bill Friske went to south Dakota
to actively campaign against the minority
leader
Tom Daschle
that is a dramatic and unprecedented move that
certainly does nothing
to advance the collegiality.
for nearly the entire history of the senate
collegiality didn't stop at the party line
but after some seat change
you're beginning to see that collegiality
is going to join the ranks
of hand written letters
soon to be considered a quaint old-fashioned
custom
this decrease in collegiality is not in
my judgment the result of having any particular
party
in control
I think it is partly the result of twenty
four hour news cycles
in which talk radio and TV personalities keep
ratings up
by engaging in strident and aggressively personal
attacks
on politicians
and that tone then spreads to discourse
on capitol hill
I certainly know something
about throwing a little partisan red meat
but I'm talking about something different
from that
it's more of a take-no-prisoners approach
to government
that I do not believe is in the best interest
of the American people
another reason for the changed tone of the
senate I believe is that today many more members
come to the senate
from the house of representatives
and the house has a very different set of
rules and atmosphere then you have historically
found in the senate
my colleagues from the house can speak more
directly to this but the party line voting
and the all-or-nothing philosophy
it permeates the house of representatives
has not been a part of the senate dynamic
until very recently
believe it or not this is also the first time
in the entire fifty years
since the graduation of the class of fifty
four
that the republican party has been in control
of both the white house and the senate
and the house of representatives
and an overwhelming majority of the federal judiciary
has been appointed
by the republican administration
often in those fifty years democrats had control
but on those occasions it was never a significant
strain on the system
of checks and balances because democratic
unity is such an unusual phenomenon
as the saying goes
we tend to line up in a circle
when we try to form a firing squad
the checks and balances
are less effective when the party in control
is more monolithic
the only real check on a bad idea today
it's a filibuster in the senate
the challenge is especially serious when the
pressure from the right is so determined
to extend its control to the judicial branch
of the government
as well
fortunately we have an election every two
years they can restore
the balance when the strain is too severe
I think of Winston Churchill often these
days
Democracy is the worst form of government
except for all the others that have been tried
from time to time
if it could transform thirteen tiny quarreling
colonies
into a free nation two hundred years ago
if it could transform Europe and Japan after
world war two
and bring down the Berlin Wall as well
it can also produced good to the many
challenges
that we face today at home and around
the world.
I'm an optimist though,
I like to think that the times are auspicious,
that we can tap into the wave of new hope
and commitments stirring in the country now
after the very moving dedication of the world
war two memorial a week ago
the sixtieth anniversary of D-DAY
we are all in this together
the greed
the special interests
the petty partisan passions
the poison politics
can't endlessly stop an idea
who's time has come.
again Churchill said it best, America will
do the right thing
after it's tried everything else
legislating is not exactly
instant gratification
in the sixties as a young Senator I was drawn
to the issue of civil rights education and
health care
and I still am
and Harvard’s been an indispensable resource
you can assemble the best minds on any
issue
and then try to form a coalition of the willing
to fight for it.
usually you have to sustain some losses and
then regroup
we you can come back to fight again
most of the real gains and policies happen
that way
incrementally
nothing happens if you let the best
become the enemy of the good
we've been struggling for two hundred years
to fulfill the promise of equal opportunity
for all
the year the class of fifty four graduated
was the year of the modern revolution in
civil rights began
with the landmark school desegregation decision
by the supreme court
we've made progress since then
but we know that civil rights is still the
unfinished business
of America
in education we began to argue in congress
the sixties about aid
to low-income students and high poverty districts
and we still are
and today we continue those battles and higher
education we still have glaring
inequalities
and qualified low-income students only a quarter
is likely to attend college as the more
qualified but wealthy as equally qualified
or no more
qualified than
but wealthier fellow students
the GI bill for the world war two generation
wasn't early giant step
but we still have miles to go to close the gap
The president
has announced an enormously interesting innovative
program
that any child that is basically
in the bottom third
of the economic income but is able to
meet the criteria are the standards here at
Harvard before the income from forty thousand
dollars less
will not
have to pay
the tuition
leading
advance and in terms of colleges
that challenge other colleges
across this country
health care policy is never easy either
in nineteen fifty four we were just a few years
away from Harry Truman’s
unsuccessful effort to enact universal health
care
still hasn't happened
even though every other industrial nation
the world did it
years ago, made health care
a fundamental right for all
we shouldn't be going it alone
on foreign policy
and we shouldn't be pretending
on health care that everyone is out of step
but Uncle Same. let me
when my brother Jack was in congress and senate
in the nineteen forties and fifties the senate
would recess
in June
for the rest of the year
some members spent more time on the links
of the burning tree country club
than on the floor the united states senate
but with the seriousness of the issues on
civil rights and the war in Vietnam the senate
changed
to a five-day week
twelve month calendar with some votes
being held between Christmas and new year's
day
the challenges facing the country
were too important to ignore
the time in actual session is shorter
now
we don't get out in June but votes usually only
take place between Tuesdays and Thursdays
there are many more recesses than there used
to be and they are longer
but the problems that we're facing in our
country are as great
as or greater than at any time in our nation's
history
and I believe that we will rise
to meet them
it took Lyndon Johnson’s landslide in nineteen
sixty four
to make Medicare happen in nineteen sixty
five
and a John Kerry landslide in two thousand four
might just be what the doctor ordered for
two thousand five
thank you very much